-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to the show, everybody!
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is the type
of New York City spirit
you're gonna get.
Welcome, everybody.
-Jimmy!
-I'm so happy you're here.
Guys, guess what's finally here.
The summer Olympics
kick off tomorrow.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The official motto
for this year's Olympics
is "United by Emotion."
Yeah, and
the unofficial motto is
"As of right now,
we're still doing it."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Tomorrow's the big day,
and all of our best athletes
have arrived in Tokyo.
Legends like Simone Biles,
Katie Ledecky...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Kevin Durant...
...and a dancing horse
named Butterscotch.
[ Cheers ]
Meanwhile, as if all the COVID
concerns around the Games
aren't bad enough,
a bear was spotted
inside the softball stadium...
[ Laughter ]
...and is still on the loose.
What an Olympics
this is gonna be.
I mean, between the bears
and getting a disease,
it's like we sent our athletes
to a game of "Oregon Trail."
[ Laughter ]
It's not a good situation.
Apparently, the bear got really
agitated after officials made
him sleep on a cardboard bed.
[ Laughter ]
But officials are working hard
to make sure everyone stays safe
and healthy
at this year's Games.
But some people are still
unclear about what rules
the athletes have to follow
in Olympic Village.
So here to clear things up
is Olympics spokesman Ron Hobbs.
Ron?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ron, what is the IOC's
official policy
on getting together
and socializing in person?
-Jimmy, we'd never tell
these world-class competitors
what they can or can't do.
We're simply discouraging people
from engaging
in unnecessary physical contact.
-Right.
Maybe you could clarify
"unnecessary physical contact"?
-Simply put, no hanky-panky.
[ Laughter ]
No two-person push-ups.
No knocking boots.
No boffing, boinking,
buttering the biscuits,
boom-boom, bouncy-bouncy,
or bow-chicka-wow-wow.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Thank you.
Is that -- Is that why the beds
are made of cardboard?
-Actually,
the beds are just about
sustainability and recycling.
But if they happen to discourage
a game of human Tetris,
so be it.
[ Laughter ]
Because there should be
no grown-up nap time,
no baking the potato,
no horizontal hula,
glazing the doughnut,
greasing the loaf pan,
or squat jumping
in the cucumber patch.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. I --
[ Laughter continues ]
I feel like
you're trying to say something
without really saying it.
And that's...
-Let me rephrase.
No tangling the downstairs
Christmas lights.
-Okay.
-No ordering fries "animal
style" from In-N-Out Burger.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
[ Laughter continues ]
-No making bacon,
making whoopee, or...
♪ Makin' my way downtown,
walking fast ♪
♪ Faces pass and I'm homebound ♪
-Yeah, I know -- okay, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maybe you should just tell us
the full list
of what's not allowed.
-Sure thing.
No rolling in the hay,
no digging up sand crabs,
no dipping the candle wick,
sweeping the chimney,
opening the Gates of Mordor,
letting the Joker
in the Batcave,
doing the Monster Mash,
rummaging in the root cellar,
searching for pocket change,
shocking the monkey,
shrimping the barbie,
shucking the oyster,
shellacking the canoe,
testing the suspension,
battering the corn dog,
getting busy, getting down,
getting it on,
getting some strange,
getting some
stank on the hang down,
doing the nasty,
the wild thing,
or doing the hoody-hoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Sorry. What I meant to say is,
what is allowed?
-Well, uh,
hand stuff is fine.
-Okay, thank you, Ron.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ron Hobbs, everyone.
Thank you, very much.
Enjoy the Olympics.
-In-N-Out Burger.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's not all
people are confused about
when it comes to the Olympics.
There's a lot
of misinformation out there,
so I thought it'd be helpful
to break down what's fact
and what's fiction
about this year's Games.
For example, Simone Biles
may attempt a Yurchenko
double pike vault
and half-on with two twists.
Fiction,
that's her Starbucks order.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not true.
-Yeah, it's not true.
-Next up,
Facts -- karate, skateboarding,
sport climbing, and surfing,
are making their Olympic debut.
Fiction --
Frisbee golf is next, brah.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, fact -- the Games
will have no spectators.
Fiction -- When they heard,
badminton players were like,
"Wait.
You can have spectators?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's fiction.
They know that.
Switching gears, last night,
Fox News aired a 10-second
public-service announcement
urging viewers
to get the vaccine.
[ Audience murmuring ]
Although it didn't help when
they ended the PSA by saying,
"Just so you know, this could be
the microchip talking."
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered "Oohs" ]
Some tech news.
[ Chuckles ]
I saw that Amazon --
Amazon's Alexa just rolled out
a male voice assistant,
and his name is Ziggy.
[ Laughter ]
Right now,
Jeff Bezos is thinking,
"I go to space for 11 minutes
and you name the voice Ziggy?
What's going on?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I heard that Twitter
is testing a new feature
that lets users
upvote and downvote tweets.
It's great.
It's like executives
looked at Twitter and thought,
"How can we make this place
even more toxic?"
[ Laughter ]
"Your grandma's 90th birthday?"
Enh!
[ Laughter ]
"No, thanks."
Well, this isn't good.
I read that muffins
sold at Walmart and 7-Eleven
have been recalled
over concerns about listeria.
Walmart apologized
while 7-Eleven just slapped on
a sticker that said
"Listeria flavored."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'll take two of those."
And, finally,
this is going viral.
Teenagers in New Jersey
were celebrating a birthday
on one of those slingshot rides
at an amusement park
when something
unexpected happened.
Watch this.
-All right.
Happy birthday.
-Bye!
[ Screaming ]
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
That girl will now go
through her life with a phobia
of not just rides
but birthdays, in general,
I mean, that's one of
the scariest things --
Can we see that again?
That's insane.
[ Both screaming ]
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Afterward, her friend was like
"Yeah, we're definitely gonna
buy the photo from that ride."